listen I've been thinking really about
why we're so good together why is that
well you're crazy match is my crazy big
time mmm
and we're like two jigsaw pieces you
know the weird curvy edges but you fit
them together and you see the picture on
top please there's something I've been
meaning to ask you
only because you haven't gotten around
to asking me well you are stupid
marry me
jinx huh are you hiding no where Wade
Wilson
when I'm finished it mutates it cells
will heal anything but you think we're
making your superior we're making you
musubi slave we'll see about that posh
spice
no look at me I know I don't want it
exactly
oh there's the money shot baby
hey youtubers it's Charlie so new
Deadpool trailer the chimichangas that
bind if you guys don't remember there
was this big event in comics a long time
ago where Jean Grey got married to Scott
Summers later they Lampoon that when
Deadpool got married to another Marvel
character he was a lot of fun but let's
talk about this ring pop I definitely do
not want to know how many licks it takes
to get to the center of that o-ring pop
where are you hiding that nowhere I know
they've been teasing this movie as a
love story
and yes Morena Baccarin is playing
copycat from the comics obviously
they're taking the character in a
slightly different direction because on
paper she looks almost exactly like what
Jennifer Lawrence would look like when
she was in her mystique costume so
obviously Fox doesn't want to duplicate
that character in the powers that
copycat has are very similar looking to
what mystique has even though she's more
powerful
technically what copycat does is much
more complex than what mystique does
copycat has full mimicry meaning that if
you were to mimic Wolverines powers she
could mimic adamantium mystique would
just have something that would look like
adamantium like she wouldn't actually be
able to replicate that metal and in the
comics copycat never got married to
Deadpool she was this crazy crazy
ex-girlfriend type character that
infiltrated x-force to try and get
closer to Deadpool mimic some other
characters that she thought the Deadpool
was interested in had sexual
relationships with cable couple other
characters eventually she ended up dying
Deadpool saved her and she went on to
work this chimie Chonga Stan it was kind
of this funny ending where it's like
yeah we're fridging the character but
we're not really fridging the character
she came back in a funny way remember
when I said Deadpool got married in the
wedding was kind of lampooning the
wedding of Jean Grey and Scott Summers
from the 90s copycat came back during
that storyline to try and derail the
wedding cause a bunch of mischief it was
a lot of fun that actually happened
relatively close to when the Deadpool
test footage leaked in 2014 at Comic Con
remember that set off the chain of
events that led to us actually getting a
full-blown Deadpool movie r-rated
Deadpool movie but the only really
Deadpool gets married storyline was that
shakeela storyline went the one the
copycat came back to try and derail so
I'm wondering what's going on in the
Deadpool movie obviously they're teasing
it is a love story Morena Baccarin
character is a slightly more emotionally
complex version of the cop
catid the comics I'm not expecting her
to be a metahuman and we'll see I
haven't been to any of the test
screening so I have absolutely no idea
the big surprise that everyone's teasing
happening at the end of the movie I
think that that's something else I don't
think it's copycat related and another
big problem is is that Morena Baccarin
is a series regular on Gotham they shoot
20-plus episodes of season I think it's
actually like 22 episodes of season so I
don't know if she'd be able to come back
for a sequel if they did the Deadpool on
cable movie that they've been talking
about the writer of this movie has been
teasing Deadpool 2 will be Deadpool on
cable no no idea what they would call it
but I guess that they would probably try
and call it Deadpool on cable other big
stuff in this trailer Gina Carano
full-blown wrestling with Colossus that
is gonna be awesome now she's playing
angel dust from the comics they changed
her character just a little bit to think
they beefed her up big time but her
powers work the same way they do in the
comics she's actually part of a lesser
branch of the Morlocks that Grant
Morrison originated so of course Grant
Morrison is gonna create a character
called angel dust and under some crazy
hallucinatory drug but the Morlocks are
supposed to appear in x-men apocalypse
so there will be more locked characters
inside like this greater x-men Fox
universe I think what they're trying to
do and obviously we haven't seen these
movies yet so we don't know if it's
going to be successful is they're trying
to build them out as much as possible
because big actors are leaving they're
looking to raise new talent they want to
create a richer universe so it's it's
easier to mask the disappearance of Hugh
Jackman when you have a bunch of awesome
new characters that everybody loves but
the trick is is writing really awesome
characters when we haven't seen that yet
we haven't seen the movie just to throw
forward a little bit it's a little early
to be talking about this but Bryan
Singer has already signed on for the
next x-men film so whatever they end up
doing in the wake of apocalypse is
attack it is going to be a Bryan Singer
story which i think is good it'll be
consistent I think after that I'll be
more open to a new director coming in
and it looking a little bit different
but I almost forgot a lot of you been
asking me about this one particular shot
this one particular fight scene where it
looks like Deadpool is fighting on a
Helicarrier now we all know the shield
helicarrier's from the Marvel movies
there is no agreement between Fox and
Marvel that we know about now so if this
is a Helicarrier it's going to be a
little bit different from the shield
helicarrier's but it does look like
these are giant turbines for raising the
ship up
the weird thing about this though is a
look at the deck look at how ratty like
nasty this looks it almost looks like
there's a garbage yard on top of this so
maybe this isn't a salvage yard maybe
this is a Helicarrier that someone is
repurposed or like like a bunch of
pirates have stolen without more
information I'm just gonna assume that
it belongs to Ajax's Weapon X group
they're really like a subset of the
Weapon X program so it'll be interesting
to see how the movie explains them I
would just think of them as a shady
offshoot of the Weapon X program now
remember the x-men timeline is a little
bit different than this Deadpool movie
Deadpool seems like it's happening in
present day or at least in the last 10
years x-men apocalypse is timeline is
still back in the 80s even though it's
happening after Days of Future past so
the x-men have not quite caught up but
we do see cerebro in this trailer so I'm
guessing that they're going to be
acknowledging what's going on with the
x-men at this time so time to get hyped
we're only a couple weeks away from the
movie coming out I'll be doing a couple
more Deadpool videos in the next couple
weeks so be sure to subscribe to get
everything in slightly related news I
just did a Batman V Superman trailer
video last night but they did just
release this image that is almost too
awesome to not talk about so I might do
a video about Darkseid in the Justice
League universe I'll just say right away
even though you know I haven't made the
video yet do not take this picture at
face value this is a classic example of
false narration like this isn't actually
happening in the movie but it is a scene
from the movie so you kind of get the
idea well you guys wait for me to post
that video you can click here for that
Batman V Superman trailer that I posted
last night and you can click here for
all my other deadpool videos thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you